au delà de la vaccination obligatoire
des soignants et de l'extension du pass
sanitaires les corps médical s'inquiète
des départs de plus en plus nombreux
dans les hôpitaux
voyez à ce sujet ce qu'on pense tirer
amoureux le porte parole du syndicat des
professionnels infirmiers
il faut bien comprendre que lors de la
première vague nous avions six patients
kovy de pour une infirmière et ces
derniers temps nous étions à huit
patients qu'aux vite par infirmière
c'est à dire 30 % de charge de travail
supplémentaire que en supprimant des
postes en aggravent la situation de ceux
qui restent donc ça fait encore plus de
départ cette fois-ci volontaires est en
fait ils sont en train d'asphyxier
l'hôpital public en renfermant des lits
en supprimant des postes